[Music]
what did you think of hereditary tag us
in your Stardust reaction this is not a
start-up sponsored video people just
wanted to throw that in there
does that took ten minutes to put
together yes so we watched hereditary at
a special screening and we're getting
this up at a time when you guys have had
a chance to see it already that's the
way we roll this movie was one unique
experience at the theaters in mindful I
think if you've seen the trailers it
lives up to the trailers there's a
couple of solid moments in there where
the audience was there's one very
specific moment to or the whole crowd
just oh my hands went up in the air yeah
my jaw dropped a mile and I didn't put
it back up for like three straight
minutes not even like a like disgusting
thing I don't want to give it away but
it's not like oh Cory it's just
wrenching yeah there's an effect about
this film the setup of this movie Toni
Collette has a family daughter named
Charlie son named Peter get from Jumanji
husband who was showing treatment be a
real burn they actually produced this
the movie Gabriel Byrne and Toni
Collette the movie starts off where Toni
Collette smother has passed away she's
someone who's dealt with death before
then from there things just kind of go
weird yeah I kind of viewed this movie
in a sense it's not shot like a 70s
horror film in the tone and style I you
know and not someone who's popular to
talk about on the internet but Roman
Polanski I did kind of compare some of
this to Rosemary's Baby if you saw the
trailer for mother you thought that was
like Rosemary's Baby the movies not this
movie feels more like Rosemary's Baby to
me spiritually it's very yeah because
it's a descent into madness really it's
as you put it it's very deliberately
paced it starts off really slow and
eerie it starts off on a dour of a tone
and then it just gets more dreadful as
it keeps comin worse
and the tensions heightened and you do
have this kind of movie that shapes up
to be part psychological horror and then
you know really overt it's a hard movie
to go into without giving stuff away and
one thing I love about the trailers like
there's a couple of things that I
thought the trailers to give away and
like brief flashes other than that
there's so much context in the movie
that the trailers don't go into that I
wouldn't want to like really reveal much
this is a very tense and uncomfortable
experience I feel like this movie has a
pretty clear midpoint the first half it
feels like a very metaphorical film
starts you out feeling almost like a bob
yeah about like the horrors of grief and
it's not like a ghost story
babadook has its elements that are
metaphors for grief as well but this is
done in a completely different kind of
execution it's within several members of
a family you think they're all just
falling apart because the horrors of the
emotions of grief yeah the director even
said this is partly based on you know
just like a real time that we've all
experienced whereas things keep going
wrong and you start to believe you're
cursed the curse element sort of starts
to play and harder as the movie goes
along and then the last hop you start to
get some more information things that
you expect from the trailer that hint at
every day audience horror movie fans not
pop yeah and the sense that it's a film
you get a lot of great things in there
the cinematography is beyond excellent
it really steady motion lightly framed
composed shot just from the opening shot
of this movie - one thing I also noticed
is the way they use visual transitions
and visual motifs in this movie is like
top notch because yeah they'll have a
tilt that rests on something or a pan
that comes to rest on something and then
a few scenes later that thing will come
back in a significant way and that
happens throughout the movie and just as
a visual piece it is really expertly
crafted part of the transitions is to
deal with how great the sound design is
yeah you've got a lot of pulsing sort of
again ominous tone there's one
consistent ominous tone that place
through a lot of the film yeah
like weird sub-base this is uh writing
and directing feature debut by arias
aster and you would not suspect that
this is his first time no it's it's so
wish yeah so like he's done short films
but for a feature that's over two hours
long surprises a guy's first film yeah
serious one I guess this is based on
shorts that kind of inspired this mega -
yeah so I mean he knows this material is
hidin out you cannot know how I was
phrasing it was I feel like it's a fine
script I don't think it's an amazing
script I feel like it's a fine script
the things that make this movie in the
great territory the technical execution
of its sound design its editing its
cinematography amazing performances I
would be very bummed if Toni Collette
was not recognized at all for a
performance here if she was nominated
for The Sixth Sense
yeah she should be down at The Sixth
Sense I'm insane like that's a horror
movie this is also a horror movie
without much more demanding performance
she leads this thing like it's nobody's
business and she sells everything they
have her do because her character
arguably goes through the most different
iterations and forms the toni collette
really is like the pinnacle of this
movie a greatness named an emotion she
puts it on display of those things were
it's not so much about the dialogue or
you know hugely Pilate moments a lot of
it you're just peering in on these
people's lives
yeah very slice of life in that way I
think the surprise performer for me
maybe cuz I just don't really know his
work is Alex wolf for him to be in such
a serious role and a very demanding role
and there's specific plot points that
deal heavily with his character because
it really makes it seem like he's
utilized in it but we need more of a
supporting character than Gabriel Burton
is in this movie he's like the second
lead as far ya concerned he's the
character for Hugh might actually have
the most issues with it but he wins you
over without great of a performance yes
you might sympathize with him and a
totally Dona Colette there are so many
dimensions going on in these
performances and yeah like the whole
cast overall I mean also got Gabriel
Byrne you got and out Millie Shapiro who
plays Charlie the daughter like everyone
does a really
great job you know elevating the script
and you know really adds to horrific
life what I would say to talk about why
I love this film this is a film
experience it's it is one of those films
where I'm like you will appreciate this
more than the theaters or when you watch
at home with the lights off and it is
one of those movies too that will
germinate in your mind the more time you
sit with yeah it's a film to dissect
it's one of those things with like
little details throughout that anytime I
like slightly wasn't paying attention I
kind of worried and don't be married to
any one set of expectations because you
might miss the details you wouldn't have
been looking yeah otherwise I find that
there's a lot of very uncomfortable
moments and like there's a the first
half is just like flat out uncomfortable
that's quieting uncomfortable yeah
there's almost no levity in this movie
it's it's fury
I was never exactly terrified I know
some people are it's a different kind of
scare I wasn't scared but I was
horrified quite a bit like I think it is
one of those movies that truly
translates the horrific not necessarily
the aggressive their parts but yeah the
horrific truly and it's not like a fun
horror movie by any capacity yeah there
are a couple moments of pitch-black
humor but other than that yeah it's it's
pretty ominous the entire time and then
when the movie was done we were there
like a small group of people more
supernatural elements started coming
into play when the movie really goes
crazy yeah the movie starts to go really
especially by the finale just it just
goes nuts it is a build over time as we
descend we're also building up in the
pace in the tones so this is not the
movie forward we didn't show up to the
theater with and we don't really know
these people and a couple of strangers
the one spot that was debated because
we're all like yeah it's great it deal
with the one spot that's debated is the
finale and the fairy and I'm talking
about the very end
yeah like the last 10 ish minutes I'm
going to tell you what it is right now
basically and even when the movie was
done so you can't help but talk about
the end that one way to take it is in a
very literal way another way to take
it's a very metaphorical way if you take
it literally it's like you kind of
if you take a metaphorical it kind of
makes you like question other things
yeah it's an ending that's to be debated
and I think we're both on the same page
about this I'm curious to see if I watch
it a second time if I'm like oh no the
endings perfect this is a movie that
will be a smoother watch the second time
because for me also it's like having one
idea in my head and having one idea of
what I'm supposed to be focusing on are
looking for for the first half of the
movie there are things you might not
pick up or there are things that might
cause you to be taken aback when the
second half of the film kicks in and
especially towards the finale kicks in I
guess without giving too much away there
are sort of two styles two approaches to
a horror film that I kind of saw working
in this thing like we touched on earlier
the sort of more metaphorical
psychological side and the very literal
very unsettling side and depending on
how you're focusing on this movie
depending on what you're looking for
from its the blend of that might or
might not coalesce for you and that's
the only thing I would I guess caution
anybody about with this movie it's like
everything is expert and it's just where
it all ends up I'm not exactly sure how
that's gonna place everybody I think the
biggest thrills come from the last half
and I and I love the last half I do I
prefer the first half even though it's
not as thrilling and it requires a much
more patient viewing experience yeah in
terms of what they were doing with
storytelling is what I prefer I feel
like the storytelling its strengths it's
not as present yet the stuff you showed
up for is really great in the second
half yeah it's an odd movie because it
gives you kind of everything you were
wanting and maybe expecting in a way
that's completely disconnecting it's not
like it's just oh that's what I expected
but yeah it ends up in an odd place by
the time you even get to the end of the
movie even though that causes a lot of
debate and there were some people who
are with who were just like I love it
just that last like few minutes like
there are people you really felt that
like I hate that and beyond that though
I wouldn't diminish this from saying
it's not 5 out of 5 stars because on an
execution level and an experience level
yeah you can't deny the film that like
in terms of going to the theater if you
know you're showing up for a creepy
unsettling horror film and you get just
that and more inside what I would
be like yeah this is a five out of five
yeah and again you know it might get
smoother for you the second time you see
it or just you know if you're looking
for something different going in and I
feel like having a divisive coda a
divisive ending actually just kind of
strengthens my appreciation of this yeah
because it definitely goes for it and it
shows me some things that are horrifying
in a way that I haven't seen in a while
even sitting here now it's like we saw
this last night and I'm already feeling
different things about the ending
thinking back in different ways than I
was you know right when we'd walked out
of the movie or whatever all right guys
well did you see her reddit area to live
up to the hype because the film has
amazing reviews on Rotten Tomatoes I'm
wondering right now if it's gonna be one
of those like 40% audience or 90% are
you or Saturday then it comes at night
another a Tony for joint you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons are pretty much broken you can
check us out on patreon full line TV
show reactions weekly Q&A s would love
to have you become a patron eject